はじめ）こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
まさき）まさき取締役で～す
は）双眼鏡ってご存知でしょうか
は）知ってますか？
ま）知ってます、もちろん
は）うわっ！
ま）肌ァっていうなｗ
は）で  これ遠くのものが
見えるんですけども
は）やはり一つの双眼鏡だと
限界があると
は）ある程度の距離のところまで
しか見えないので
は）めちゃくちゃ遠くのものを
は）ちょっと盗み見したいなと
思ったときに
は）これだけだとちょっと見えないと
は）いうことが起きてしまいます
は）というわけで今日はですね
この双眼鏡をたくさん準備しました
は）はい
は）はい！
は）17？
ま）17
は）合計17個の双眼鏡を準備しました
は）で  今回なんですけども
は）ちょっと限界まで
双眼鏡の限界まで迫ろうと思って
は）これ　要するに
は）目に見える倍率が
上がるわけじゃないですか
は）なんでこれをこう
は）2つドッキングさせると
は）たとえばこれであの
は）10倍の距離が見えるとしましょう
は）で  これが10倍の距離が
見えるとしましょう
は）これとこれを掛け合わせると
は）何倍になるでしょうか
ま）www
は）なにw
ま）その、その計算絶対正しくないw
は）いやいやいや
は）10倍×10倍は？
ま）100倍
は）そういうことですよ
は）100倍先のものまで
は）見えてしまうということになります
は）12倍だ！
ま）え？もっとじゃん、じゃあ
は）すごいな
は）12倍×12倍で
は）144倍まで見えますね
ま）そんなに見えんの？
は）12倍が17個あるので
は）えっと、12の17乗
は）が！肉眼で見える倍率になります
は）もう千里眼ですよ！
は）とりあえず開けていきましょう
は）はい  というわけで17個の双眼鏡が
ここに今 揃いました
は）まあ  とりあえず参考までに
は）でございます
ま）いらないね
は）10個で...10個で600億倍までなるから
は）で 今回、僕がやりたいのは
は）えっと 山にいる人を見たいなって
は）その山にいる人とかなんか物とかを
は）見れたらすごい
いいなって思ったんですけど
は）たぶん619億倍までいらないと思うんで
は）8個だったらちなみに…
は）それでも4億倍か…
ま）うん
は）4億倍もいらないんだよなあ…
は）あっ  てか、あれだ！
は）じゃ 今回の企画なんですけど
は）まさきくんに山に行ってもらいます
ま）前提がおかしいじゃん、もう
は）山に行ってもらって
は）で  山にいるまさきをこうやって見ると
は）で 1個で
「あー ちょっと遠いな」って思ったら
は）もう1個 こう付け足します
は）ピント合わせながらこうやって
やってって…
は）あーー  これすごいわ
は）もう今  カーテンが…
ま）絶対うそでしょw
は）1個でまず 見てみて
「あー ちょっと遠いな」って思ったら
は）もう1個 こうやって
ピント合わせて付け足してゆく
は）それでも「ちょっと多いな」
って思ったら
は）こう  もう1個ピント合わせて
付け足してゆくと
は）これ繰り返して最終的に
は）山にいる彼をしっかりと
こうなんか
は）見れたら…
は）いいね！
ま）www
は）そういう企画でございます
は）それでは早速まさきくんに
山に行ってもらいましょう
は）ではいこう！
は）はい、というわけで
今 まさきくんを
は）山の方へ行かせております
ま）はい、ということで 今
ま）高い…
ま）ところ
ま）に向かっております
【電話の呼出音】
は）わぁっ！びっくりした
は）きたきた
【電話の呼出音】
ま）もしもーし？
は）はいはい？
ま）今、着いてとりあえず
は）着いたの？
ま）うん  位置情報送った
は）位置情報送った  はーい
は）待って  それ俺のカステラだよ？
ま）え？
は）これ俺のお茶だよ？これは
ま）www
は）お茶は  だーめ
は）ww  頭おかしくなってねーわ
は）今ちょっと確認してみまーす
は）もう 登ってる？
ま）うん
は）え  どこどこどこ？
は）え？まったく分かんないよ？
ま）ほんとに？
は）え  ガードレールでしょ？
ま）もうちょっと動いてみる？じゃあ
は）なんかできればね
ガードレールがあると
は）すごい助かるかもしれない
ま）分かった 分かった
じゃあちょっと移動してみる
は）うん  お願いしまーす
は）ほーほー
は）どーどーどー   どーどーどー
は）どーどーどーー
【犬の鳴き声】
は）ｴｪｪ ?
は）ﾝｱｧｯ !
は）ﾊﾟｳﾊﾟｳ
は）ﾜﾝ!
は）ﾝﾝ
ま）ﾝﾝﾝ
ま）ﾜﾝﾜﾝ
は）ﾜﾝ!
は）やべえ 犬がかわいい
ま）まさきとどっちがかわいい？
は）犬
ま）さよなら
は）ww 待って待って 許して
ま）www
は）ﾜﾝ!
は）あぁーー
は）おおぉー
は）おー  どーどーどーどーぅ
ま）え やばいな
は）おぉー へいへいへい
は）そこは俺の大切な
は）大切な息子
は）ちょっとね
は）了解しました、ちょっと もう たぶん
は）ビデオカメラだと見えないんで
は）早速、双眼鏡1個使って見ていきます
ま）雨がだんだん…
は）いや これむずいぞ
は）ガードレールある？
ま）ガードレールある
今ガードレール…
ま）の横に立ってる
は）ガードレールの横
ちょっと探してみます
ま）ガードレールのすぐ前
は）え？まさかこれか？
は）今ガードレールの前にいる？
ま）うん、ガードレールの前
は）双眼鏡1つで もう小さすぎて
確認できないので
は）まず2つ合体させてみましょう
は）これで多分 かなり
は）めちゃくちゃ近くのところまで
見えるようになると思うんで
は）これならきっとまさきくんを
は）結構 早く見つけられるのかな
と思います
は）はい できました！
は）では 見ていきます！
は）すいません すいません！
すいません すいません！
ま）はい
【悲しげなBGM】
ま）どあほー！
【ED】